that was actually the last question i
thought it's good god is good
i've been going all day
and uh it's good to rest even
there's a hand
okay
all right so let's um use the mic so
that we can
don't let these hands turn into a forest
all right danny puts me on the spot okay
yes
you know in regards to healing
the sabbath so say they weren't getting
paid on this sabbath would that change
things
you don't work on the sabbath
okay jesus said it's lawful to do good
he did not say it's lawful to work you
see if you excuse sabbath work which
gains pay then you must excuse the
firemen and you must excuse because they
have good arguments you must excuse the
policeman you may have to excuse the fbi
agent they quite if you having this fbi
agent the ten churches in washington dc
we cannot make an exception for any
commandment okay once you do that you
open the floodgates to make exceptions
for all the other nine
in it thou shalt not do any work
and trust god to take care of you
there's a reason why god did not send
manna on sabbath
the enemy is that which keeps your life
you understand because they complained
they were hungry they're about to die he
said man about not on sabbath which
means god does not provide a living on
the sabbath
as i said sometime and unto whom
if you make a living on the sabbath it
didn't come from god
it did not come from god
the devil can give you things don't
misunderstand me but it did not come
from god yes can you repeat the um
uh text from medical missionary
page 216 paragraph two page two sixteen
paragraph two
the chapter is the the sanitarium family
something like that
all right where's the other hand